to the phones we go atlanta georgia is
where we're going to pick up
bill bill how can we help yes sir i
appreciate y'all taking my call
uh y'all doing all right gentlemen oh we
are really having a blast what's going
on
good uh forgive me i'm gonna be a little
bit nervous about this
oh you're doing great i am 62 years old
i am a truck driver uh i
am on baby step number four i'm thinking
about going back to online school
for i.t an i.t profession
uh it's just getting i i do enjoy my job
but it's just getting physically harder
on me every day and so i never plan
on actually retiring just maybe cutting
back on my hours
so i thought maybe getting into the i.t
field
would be something that would come up
maybe
years from now that i could get into
where i could quit driving a truck and
start doing that
uh the community college in my area
offers some certificate programs at i.t
of different subjects uh and i was
wondering if
uh y'all thought that would be the best
way to go
well i think it's a really good way to
go i think you get to determine if it's
the best way to go
in the sense of is technology what you
really want to do in these later seasons
it certainly gives you that flexibility
and something that you can begin doing
pretty quickly
you know once you get that certification
and you can begin to to get
opportunities to do it even while you're
in the truck you know some freelance
type work i think it gives you a lot of
versatility
but what makes this is this the best
move
uh is this if this is what you really
want to do i will tell you that you
don't have to have a ton of technical
experience
to get technically qualified to be able
to do work like
technology i mean i work with a great
organization that's training people
in nine months so you know that's the
issue if this is something you really
want to do
yeah i think you should do it and i
think you should do it as cheaply as
possible you don't need a four-year
degree
that's not something you're entertaining
anyway so it's where who can train me
to do what i want to do so the question
is do you know what type of technology
work you want to do
no sir not yet the different subjects
one of the first one i'm looking to is
just the i.t
fundamentals to get into the
uh beginning stages of it and then
probably progress from there
i don't think i'd ever be good at being
a programmer or something like that but
actually a uh a help desk specialist
or somebody that works on computers or
something like that would be something
that i would
think i would really enjoy okay great so
bill here's where we start
so you're 63 you've got a lot of
relationships you know even more people
than you think you know
and so what you've got to do is you've
got this idea i think i'd like to do
some just basic
you know computer maintenance fixes it
help
you need to start to connect with over
the phone
over lunch or coffee with somebody who's
in that
actual job and the reason you do this
this is the
equivalent of the old days when you were
in school and you would do
some type of a term paper or some type
of a report where you would research
something
and so we want to do is we want to
clarify and verify you've got an idea we
want to clarify everything that's
involved in that on a day-to-day basis
what are you doing what do these folks
like about it the most what do they like
the least
and then you want to look into all right
uh what's it going to take to get
qualified to get into that
and so that's the clarify and verify
when you look into all those answers
your heart's going to either go ding
ding ding
or the big red family feud x and so bill
that's all you've got to do
so that's what i want you to do i want
you to really start hanging out with
or try to talk to people that are doing
that type of it work
and it's going to verify it for you
okay that sounds good i appreciate it
hey bill i want to tell you
one more thing you have just
this is this this has been a a long day
here we've been working since early this
morning i want you to know
that you have absolutely put some wind
in my sails
and you have called everyone in
america's bluff
who says this is just what i do i've
been doing this too long to to
fill in the blank um i know my back
hurts my knees hurt but i can't do any
feeling
this is what i'm talking about bill of
somebody who's looking to the future and
saying
i'm never too young to go learn
something new i'm never too young to go
call my local community college class i
got the courage
to do something different to do
something hard to change my mind
to do both and bill i want to tell you
you're a hero without a cape on
and i'm grateful that you called here
you're going to help
people so much get over that hump that i
can't it's too i'm too old it's too late
that's right all that is bull crap you
can you just gotta decide
i'm gonna go suck it up and i'm gonna go
get a certificate i'm gonna go like ken
said i'm gonna go sit down and talk to
somebody
and bill i'd hug you if you were here
i'm so grateful that you called man
yeah you're not too old it's not too
late the reason that people aren't sure
if they can
john is because they don't know how
right when we figure out the how
and i mean that when i say we've all
done a term paper in high school or
college but it's different even the how
though because
it's it's bill's got a it could easily
be
i don't i i'm going to feel
uncomfortable sitting in a club in a in
a
college class that's like a 19 year old
that's true yep you are yeah yeah
you're right you have once you are
confronted with the how you still have
to do it to go do it there's no question
about it
but i'm telling you one of the biggest
obstacles for folks
is they they they have this idea that
i'm too old i can't do it it's going to
be too expensive it's going to take too
long
and they're filling in the answers
themselves they don't have the real
answers
and that's what we're imagining a worst
case scenario
or an embarrassment or a failure and
then they reverse engineer right now and
they just stay put that's why i
love the clarify and verify just go sit
with somebody who's doing that work
yeah and answer the questions that you
don't have answers to
and all of a sudden it's not so
difficult i mean that's why i wrote the
book the proximity principle that's how
i got into broadcasting starting at 33
with no degree and no connections
i got around the people that were doing
it and i got in places where the work
was happening
i kept showing up and doing it and then
opportunities presented themselves
let's not overthink this is the point
folks and
have the courage and go do it yeah just
step out it is going to be uncomfortable
i promise you